I'll open up Chrome Dev tools emulator,
and
look at a mobile view of
the web fundamentals site.
I'll open Chrome,
navigate to Web Fundamentals,
then open the Chrome Developer Tools,
using Cmd+Option+J, or Control+Alt+J.
Next, I'll hit the emulator button.
It's that phone looking
icon in the toolbar.
Great, the emulator is ready to go.
I can start loading pages and
see how they look.
But before I do,
I like to dock the tools to the right
side of the browser window.
Since most phones
are viewed in portrait,
docking to the right side gives me
the most amount of vertical space.
The other thing I need to do is pick
the device that I want to emulate.
Chrome has a bunch of predefined
devices, that I can choose from.
It auto-magically sets the view
port size, the user agent string,
device pixel ratio, and
enables touch emulation.
If you're not familiar with some
of these terms, don't worry.
We'll cover them as part of this course.
Now I can see how a page renders
across different devices without ever
leaving Chrome.
Sweet, that looks about
how I'd expect it.
Chrome has several other
things that it can emulate for
you in the Emulation panel.
Hit Escape to bring it up.
Why don't you go check out a few sites
with different emulated devices and
see how they behave?
And, don't forget to check out some of
the other things that you can emulate
while you're there.